en el vídeo anterior definimos el
término de afinidad electrónica y vimos
las afinidades electrónicas para el
litio berilio y el boro hablamos de sus
respectivos valores y lo que significan
en términos de estructura del átomo
neutro y del guión que se forma en este
vídeo
vamos a hablar acerca de las tendencias
en la afinidad electrónica y en términos
de un patrón de grupo algunos libros de
texto dirán que hay un patrón de grupo
bastante modesto algunos libros te dirán
que no hay patrón de grupo de cualquier
forma hay un patrón más claro a través
de un periodo y debido a esto es ese el
que vamos a abordar y si analizamos
algunos de estos números aquí
empezaremos con el boro
entonces el boro cede 27 kilos por mol
de energía cuando añades un electrón al
átomo neutro cuando seguimos con el
carbono aquí más energía se libera 122
kilos por mol y se observó el oxígeno se
liberan 141 vemos que aumenta y
finalmente el flúor libera 328 aún más
energía es liberada y recuerda que entre
más energía se libera mayor será la
atracción del núcleo por el electrón por
lo tanto el átomo tendrá mayor afinidad
por el electrón así que la afinidad de
electrónica aumenta y esto a veces
preocupa a los estudiantes porque
piensan acerca de este signo negativo
pero recuerda el signo negativo solo
significa que se libera energía solo
piensa en la magnitud si el signo
negativo te confunde así el flúor
liberaría 328 kilos por mol esta sería
la mayor nuevamente al recorrer un pero
en general hay un incremento en la
afinidad electrónica y también hay
varias excepciones a este patrón general
del que hablamos en el vídeo anterior
hablamos de por qué el berilio no tiene
afinidad por un electrón y también
mencionamos la razón por la cual este
número y este número no coinciden del
todo con nuestro patrón entonces primero
hablaremos de por qué ese patrón general
es cierto así que conforme recorres un
periodo
estás incrementando en términos de carga
nuclear así el boro tiene 5 protones en
el núcleo el carbono tiene 6 protones en
el núcleo y así hay un incremento en el
número de protones y no hay mucha
diferencia en términos del
apantallamiento de electrones y por eso
tu carga nuclear efectiva aumenta
conforme recorres un periodo y así la
carga nuclear efectiva es la carga que
sentiría el electrón que estás añadiendo
por lo tanto debido a que tu carga
nuclear efectiva está aumentando el
electrón que estás añadiendo al átomo
neutro sentirá una mayor fuerza de
atracción por lo tanto el átomo ha
incrementado su afinidad por ese
electrón y esta es la razón del patrón
general que vemos aquí la razón de estos
números para el boro el carbono el
oxígeno y el flúor es el aumento del
número de protones en el núcleo
vamos a pensar en una de las excepciones
a este patrón general podemos ver que el
nitrógeno tiene una afinidad electrónica
de 0 lo que significa que requerirá
energía para añadir un electrón a un
átomo neutro de nitrógeno vamos a pensar
en esto en términos de configuraciones
electrónicas para el nitrógeno la
configuración electrónica del nitrógeno
sería 1 s 2 2 s 2
y 2 p 3 entonces si quieres poner eso en
notación de orbitales aquí tenemos el
orbital 1s orbital 2s y después tenemos
3 orbitales p en el segundo nivel de
energía así que vamos a poner esos
electrones entonces tenemos vamos a
continuar cambiando los colores aquí
tenemos 2 electrones en el orbital 1 s
así que estos serían nuestros 2
electrones 2 electrones en el orbital 12
y después cuando llegamos a los
orbitales p tenemos 3 electrones d vamos
a poner un electrón en este orbital p
no en este y finalmente uno en este así
que este es un átomo neutro si
quisiéramos añadir un electrón al
nitrógeno podemos ver que aquí hemos
llenado a la mitad el psuv orbital p
entonces si vamos a añadir un electrón
vamos a añadir un electrón a uno de
estos orbitales p y digamos que añadimos
un electrón a este de aquí así que el
electrón que añadimos en magenta tiene
que ocupar el mismo espacio que el
electrón en verde por eso cuando formas
el par de giro de estos electrones allí
eso incrementa la cantidad de repulsión
electrón electrón porque allí estos dos
electrones están ocupando el mismo
orbital desde luego esa repulsión extra
significa que esto no es favorable
energéticamente
si fuéramos a añadir un electrón al
nitrógeno
ahora tenemos una carga negativa ya no
sería 2 p 3 sino 2 p 4 otra vez esa
repulsión electrón electrón extra es la
razón que normalmente ves en los libros
de texto explicando por qué el nitrógeno
no tiene afinidad por un electrón lo
siguiente es hablar del neón aquí está
el neón y el neón tampoco tiene una
afinidad por un electrón así que aquí la
afinidad electrónica es cero
y vamos a reflexionar porque ese es el
caso el número de protones en el neón es
10 su número atómico es 10 así que hay
10 protones en el núcleo entonces
tenemos 10 cargas positivas en el núcleo
así
y hay 10 electrones así que si pensamos
en dónde están esos electrones hay 2
electrones en la capa interna aquí está
mi representación bastante burda de la
capa interna con 2 electrones y tenemos
8 electrones en esta capa de aquí en
este segundo nivel de energía hay 8
electrones en esta capa de esta manera y
si piensas en añadir un electrón al neón
hagámoslo y escribamos aquí la
configuración electrónica del neón
entonces el lyon sería
s 22 s 22
6 y vamos a hablar de donde estoy
obteniendo esos números para mi diagrama
de aquí así que los dos electrones en la
capa interna serían estos dos electrones
y los ocho en esta capa externa aquí
serían dos
cierto
así 2 y 6 dan 8 entonces esta es nuestra
configuración electrónica para el neón y
sólo es una pequeña imagen de cómo se
vería ahora si quieres añadir un
electrón al neón tu segundo nivel de
energía está lleno así que tienes que
moverte hacia el tercer nivel de energía
tienes que abrir una nueva capa así que
si quieres añadir un electrón al neón
tendrías que ir a un nuevo nivel de
energía entonces el electrón tendría que
ir al orbital
s tendremos 3 s
esto haría que ahora tenga carga
negativa y sabemos que es un nuevo nivel
de energía así que lo que podemos decir
acerca del electrón que estamos
agregando es que estará en promedio más
lejos del núcleo así sería el panorama y
sabemos que este 10 positivo intentará
atraer este electrón que hemos añadido
sin embargo tienes aquí todos estos
electrones de la capa interna blindando
este otro electrón y entonces debido a
estos electrones que aquí repelen y
hacen efecto de pantalla al electrón
externo de esta carga 10 positiva el
átomo no tiene afinidad por ese electrón
en magenta que estamos añadiendo y así
que esa es la razón para el valor que
ves aquí para la afinidad electrónica
del neón
así que no tiene afinidad por un
electrón y entonces este año sería muy
inestable así que la idea es por
supuesto que el cne aún carece de la
carga nuclear suficiente no tiene
suficiente carga positiva en el núcleo
para atraer al electrón en magenta que
estaremos añadiendo aquí para formar el
año entonces esa es la idea así que
espero que esto te dé más entendimiento
sobre el patrón general para la afinidad
electrónica y también sobre algunas de
las excepciones